So let's look at the solution for our latency and throughput quiz.
We have a website that has 2 servers. A server takes a millisecond to process
an order, so the latency of an order is clearly 1 millisecond.
That's how long it takes from the time the order arrives until the time it
is actually served. The throughput of a single server, because it
cannot do anything else while processing the order, is going to be one order
per millisecond or a 1000 orders per second. But we have two such servers, so
we can process 2000 orders per second. So this illustrates again
the situation where the throughput is not just equal to 1 over the latency.
If it were like that, we would have only 1000 orders per second. But we can
buy more throughput, simply through replication of service in this case and thus
achieve a higher throughput than the latency of a single server would indicate.